hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut nach
langer Zeit gibt's auch mal wieder von
mir so ein klassisches unbox Video wie
es noch von früher gewohnt seid und ich
denke es wird spannend es geht nämlich
heute um diese wunderschönen kleinen
Pakete wie sie glaube ich jeder von euch
schon mal gesehen hat ganz normale
amazon bestellung wenn man irgendwie
eine Kleinigkeit noch braucht was auch
immer die meisten Pakete kommen mir
einfach so an ich habe für dieses Video
einfach mal 30 von diesem Paketen
bestellt und das Gute ist ich habe
keinen Plan was drin ist bin nämlich
über einen meiner Kontakte auf dieses
Thema gekommen das sind sogenannte
secret Packs also so gesehen
irgendwelche Pakete retour natürlich
auch Sachen die dann irgendwie doch
nicht ankam alles mögliche hier sind
noch weitere ja und das meiste nicht
alles aber das meiste davon ist wirklich
ungeöffnet ich frage mich auch ja doch
ja alles zu so original verpackt das
sind jetzt 15 Stück und Moment und hier
sind auch noch mal 15 Stück drin also
insgesamt halt 30 Packs bezahlt habe ich
knapp 300 €, also wer schlau schnell
rechnen kann ca 10 € pro Paket gut wenn
irgendwo ein Handy drin ist hat sich das
ja gelohnt ich bin mal gespannt sich
lohnt wirklich ich habe keine Ahnung
aber ich finde es erstmal geil und ich
freue mich Leute ganz kurz bevor wir
weitermachen mal eben Werbung in eigener
Sache und zwar habe ich mich in den
letzten zwei Wochen extrem mit einem
Projekt beschäftigt was ich jetzt gerade
gelauncht habe für diejenigen unter euch
die sich auch sehr für Retouren waren
interessieren bzw mit dem Handel von
Retouren starten möchten macht das ja
auch schon ziemlich lange habe ich mal
so einen Coaching wobei ich Coaching
irgendwie ein bisschen affig finde aber
ich habe mein ganzes Wissen aus den
letzten Jahren in so einem Kurs gepackt
wie man gut und am besten damit startet
und Geld verdienen kann zusätzlich habe
ich noch eine Liste erstellt mit
retourenhändern wo es sich wirklich Lohn
zu bestellen Retouren alphabet.de nennt
sich die Seite checkt das gerne mal ab
und ich freue mich über Leute die Bock
drauf haben so sieht das aus habe ich
alles selber gemacht und wir machen
jetzt weiter mit dem Video vom Verkäufer
kann ich euch noch folgenden
Verkaufstext Vorlesen den Inhalt kennen
wir selber nicht enthalten sind aber
wahre B-Ware zeware es können waren im
Haushalt Multimedia Textil oder Saison
enthalten sein Produkt Zustand
ungeprüfte Retouren in einem Karton sind
15 ungeöffnete kleine Amazon Retouren
Packs siehe Foto Rückgabe Umtausch wie
du nur bei ungeöffneten Packs bei
geöffnet
okay dann würde ich sagen let's go hey
ich habe mega Bock als erstes haben wir
hier ein LED Lichtstreifen von Hagemann
green Systems aha ja okay ein Spalt auch
noch perfekt neu eingepackt ist
natürlich so dass man ich versuche euch
den Preis auch immer mit einzublenden
das Gute ist ja wenn alles von Amazon
ist kann man das eigentlich direkt
erforschen okay 16,99 € gut theoretisch
6,99 plus gemacht ganz theoretisch
versuche auch die ganzen Sachen direkt
wieder einzupacken weil sonst endet das
hier in einem riesen Chaos weiter geht's
oh was haben wir denn hier
Damenunterwäsche oder was ist das Wort
hä was ist auch für für Frauen auf jeden
Fall war ja auch komplett neu eingepackt
das sind so Frauen Frauen Unterhosen
halt einfach keine Ahnung Unterhosen 10
€, ich habe jetzt nicht gefunden die
sind wahrscheinlich schon ausverkauft
oder wurden halt die verkauft er weiß
und mein realistisches Ziel ist das ein
Produkt dabei ist was alleine 100 €
kostet das könnte man ja eigentlich ja
also ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch ich
weiß ja nicht genau wer dahinter steckt
das schuf jetzt relativ realistisch ein
so ein Handy oder so wird da jetzt
vermutlich nicht und sein denke ich mal
wobei man sicherlich auch nicht
ausschließen kann das ist schon wieder
so ein LED Bums Motorrad
Zigarettenanzünder achso da sind gleich
drei Produkte drin Auto
Zigarettenanzünder und schon wieder so
ein led-dingen ja okay ist halt nichts
wildes ne okay weiter geht's hier muss
man sagen das ganze wird schon mal mit
Deutsche Post Paket man wieder
zugeklappt was ich ein bisschen stutzig
macht das geht alles an gleichen
Empfänger das ist irgendwie so eine
Firma aus bitte Heim keine Ahnung warum
bei den so viele Pakete da ankommen naja
nicht zu negativ denken hier steht ja
sogar drauf was drin ist hilfe was ist
das denn vergoldetes montiert ist
Stabilisator Set mit vergoldeten legen
dicker was ist das denn jetzt ist das
auch noch auf damit soll man auf jeden
Fall irgendwas vergolden können okay
gefunden habe ich das jetzt hier für
27,99 € aber ich habe überhaupt keine
Ahnung was das sein soll irgendwas für
die Tastatur oder so und die sind alle
auf die Dinger ich setze jetzt einfach
mal auf ein bisschen größere Pakete weil
größere Pakete da sind ja vermutlich
auch teure Sachen drin ne muss natürlich
nicht sein aber kann sein das Dumme ist
ich habe mein Messer im Lager okay was
haben wir hier drin eins ah ich check
das sind zwei Pakete die zusammengeklebt
wurden und das ist wahrscheinlich noch
mal das gleiche
hä das scheint irgendwas so für die
Tafel zu sein da kann man dann hier was
drauflegen wahrscheinlich ne ja wow
wollte schon immer mal haben vielen Dank
dafür das hier ist jetzt aber wenigstens
waren etwas schwereres Paket okay komm
bitte irgendwas wertvolles mindestens 50
Euro na ja noch mal eingepackt oh das
ist ein Licht LED Flat lights
instructions kein Stecker dabei aber ich
würde erstmal sagen das schaue ich jetzt
mal nach wie teuer das ist scheiße 21.99
irgendwie muss man ehrlich sein bis
jetzt ist nur Rotze drin egal wir sind
noch nicht am Ende nächstes Paket uii
aha das ist so ein ja das ist ein
Küchenset da kann man dann die Pfanne
mit rausnehmen Untersetzer und irgendwas
mit sauber macht wunderbar vielen Dank
dafür okay weiter geht's
ernsthaft jetzt zehn theoretisch ihr
müsst immer denken ich habe 10 € pro
Paket bezahlt pennen Mount paar
Schrauben für 10 €. ja perfekt und was
ich auch immer heftig finde ich meine
das ist ja heutzutage normal aber Leute
bestellen sich das ja und dann kommt
extra ein Postbote und liefert den drei
Schrauben
okay die nächsten Schrauben nee keine
Schrauben sondern oh okay das sieht aus
wie ein es ist ein E-Mount das sieht
erstmal nach nichts aus aber das ist ein
Ring quasi den man zwischen sein
Objektiv packen kann um es dann
kompatibel mit beispielsweise einer
Canon Kamera zu machen wenn ich jetzt
einen Sony Objektiv habe versteht ihr
was ich meine und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das relativ wertvoll ist
okay weniger als gedacht kostet 30 €. so
also zehn Pakete habe ich schon
aufgemacht Backform ja okay oder das ist
ja eine Backform also bis jetzt wirklich
nur Schrott dabei muss man ganz ehrlich
sagen und definitiv Minus gemacht also
boah wenn das so weitergeht und ich am
Ende 300 € bezahlt habe das wäre schon
bitter aber wir schauen mal haben wir
hier USB-Sticks nein das ist das denn
also bei jeder zweiten Sache da muss ich
mich erstmal fragen was ist das ah okay
das sind so Klammern und Bilder zu
befestigen an der Wand ja sowas wird das
sein und denkt dran 10 € komm schon ey
jetzt wenigstens mal eine geile Sache
junge
wow eine Kerze alles Liebe zum
Geburtstag liebe Oma all die Jahre
spannende Geschichten erzählen gemeinsam
große Abenteuer erleben jederzeit ein
offenes Ohr haben die leckersten Rezepte
weil ja irgendein Geschenk für Oma
wunderbar super spannend okay das ist
jetzt das letzte Paket aus der ersten
Box vielleicht sind er in der zweiten
Box dann bessere Sachen drin junge Mann
wir haben ja einfach ein so billig
Armbänder für 10 € man das ist fast
super traurig dass das in so einem Paket
drin ist in so einem ja da ist ja sogar
das Papier mehr wert als der Inhalt so
machen wir hier weiter mit dem nächsten
Paketen das hat erst das ist so eine so
eine Konsole aber vielleicht ist es
wirklich eine Kontrolle wow pH Meter das
sieht doch schon mal ganz gut aus wir
hoffen jetzt einfach mal dass diese
pH-Meter viel Geld kosten weil okay geil
ich hätte nicht gedacht aber dieses
Gerät kostet tatsächlich 50 € 43 somit
würde ich mal sagen wenn ich jetzt
verkaufen würde würde ich bestimmt 35
für angekommen wer jetzt das erste Paket
wo ich sage hat sich gelohnt aber das
war jetzt das erste Paket aus dem neuen
Karton das heißt es fängt schon mal gut
an hier haben wir irgendwas was schon
ausgepackt ist oh was ist das ein Tablet
ne ist das ist ein Tablet oder Navi ich
habe keine Ahnung was es ist aber es ist
teuer verpackt und das ist erstmal nicht
verkehrt hier ist sogar irgendeine CD
dabei thank you for using ich glaube das
ist so ein Tablet für die Schule komm
schon bitte Alter
die Dinger ich weiß jetzt natürlich
nicht welches Gerät das ist aber hier
ist auch der Penn dabei den man dafür
braucht wir werden hier gerade Geräte
zwischen 349 und 1190 € angezeigt das
wäre ja heftig leute das ist so ein
Grafik Tablet also man kann darauf
zeichnen ich habe das jetzt hier mal mit
meinem iMac verbunden kostet bei the way
50 € bei Kaufland also leider nicht 350
aber trotzdem okay irgendwie ist das
aber auch ein bisschen und dann kann man
halt hier drauf rum malen hier habe ich
jetzt zum Beispiel mein Stift und dann
kannst du hier einfach mal einen weiß
ich nicht
Alex wie ah geil hat er gut geklappt
also irgendwie beherrsche ich das nicht
so gut naja aber jetzt weiß ich
wenigstens was es ist und für 50 Euro
der zweite gute Fund in diesem Paket ach
so und wenn ihr wissen wollt wo ich das
ganze Zeug herab dann könnt ihr mir
einfach schreiben oder im Retouren
Alphabet ist das denke ich auch verlinkt
allerdings definitiv nicht als guter
Händler das hier ist z.B ein Paket was
schon auf war also und hier haben wir
drin es ist ein bisschen schwerer
irgendeine Batterie oder ein Akku zu
sein recharger battery pack ich habe es
geahnt ne weil das so schwerer ist das
kostet einfach
89,99 was das für ein Unterschied ist ne
das ist jetzt anscheinend die zweite
Kiste da sind die guten Sachen drin also
so langsam nimmt das hier Fahrt auf
scheint irgendwas für ein Dyson
Staubsauger zu sein oder so es kann aber
sein dass es auch das Fake Ding ist
davon dann kostet aber auch 49 90 naja
okay aber zumindest muss man sagen dass
die letzten drei Pakete auf jeden Fall
gut waren ich weiß trotzdem nicht was
ich mit dem ganzen Scheiß machen soll so
was haben wir hier
Kühe Nintendo Switch der sieht aber
schon ziemlich gebraucht aus nix wildes
kostet 15 Euro wir befinden uns auf den
letzten Metern und dieses Paket das
wollte ich eigentlich schon direkt am
Anfang aufmachen weil es für mich
eigentlich einen guten Eindruck macht
wenn man keinen scharfes Messer parat
hat und Kugelschreiber tut es auch
manchmal ah ich weiß es ach es ist ein
Hula Hoop Ring oder es sind zwei Hula
hoopringe nein es ist einer habe ich das
noch kann eins dann kommt jetzt wieder
das andere das liegt auf jeden Fall wie
ein sehr professioneller Hula hubling ey
wenn ich das gleich mindestens 5
Sekunden schaffe müsst ihr alle den
Kanal abonnieren sonst bin ich sauer
zack ist fertig auf die Plätze fertig
los tschüss was ist ein Müll kann doch
nicht einfach direkt auseinander fliegen
so jetzt aber
ja
[Musik]
man so alter das habe ich ewig gemacht
Hula Hoop abonnieren das war mindestens
zehn ja das Ding kostet 20 25 Euro
irgendwie so naja okay wir kommen zu den
letzten secret Packs sind jetzt glaube
ich die letzten fünf hier haben wir
irgendwelche Hüte oder so keine Ahnung
was das ist ich glaube das sind jetzt
wieder auch eher so Pakete die nicht so
geil sind eine European Kabel da kenne
ich die Marke wenigstens das ist schon
mal ganz gut
irgendeine Schraube
oh wir sind Ketten drin und sogar
relativ viele jetzt stellt euch mal vor
oder was ist das ach so da kann man
Bilder dran aufhängen ja komm muss ich
gar nicht nachgucken wird auch nichts
Besonderes sein eine iPhone 12 Hülle
also was mich eigentlich am meistens
hättest fight ist dass man diese ganzen
Pakete aufmachen kann das ist cool aber
oftmals ah das ist ich weiß was es ist
hier haben wir denke ich ein Handy
repair Set neues Schutz Display fürs
Note 8 black super wollte schon immer
mal haben diese Schutzhülle einfach ein
Traum ja Leute wie schon vermutet habe
ich glaube das beste haben wir
ausgepackt oh die nächste aha hier haben
wir jetzt wahrscheinlich die passenden
ach nee das ist ein Beutel wow das Ding
ist sogar kaputt perfekt
wow erstmal gedacht Smartphone dann
gedacht zu leicht ein Case fürs Google
Pixel 5a 5g ja perfekt diese beiden
Pakete habe ich noch vergessen das ist
jetzt zumindest noch etwas größeres wir
schauen mal vielleicht habe ich ja Glück
hier sind zwei headphones drin Call
Center headphone mit Kabel und das
gleiche haben wir hier noch mal drin
wenn es hochkommen kostet dazu zusammen
30 Euro
wahnsinnig und hier das ist jetzt das
letzte Paket von meinen secret Packs und
eine Powerbank das heißt ich wurde jetzt
von 30 Mal ich glaube 27 Mal enttäuscht
dreimal war es in Ordnung unterm Strich
hat sich das natürlich überhaupt nicht
gelohnt aber es war trotzdem halbwegs
interessant dass alles mal auszupacken
aber leider fast nur Schrott naja ich
hoffe euch hat's trotzdem gefallen
nächste Woche kommt ein cooles Video ich
habe nicht zustellbare verloren
gegangene Pakete von DHL gekauft auch
ein bisschen mehr deswegen glaube ich
dass das auf jeden Fall cooler und
spannender wird als das jetzt wobei das
ja auch an sich ganz lustig war aber
abonniert sehr gerne den Kanal check das
Retouren Alphabet ab falls ihr euch
dafür interessiert und ich sage haut
rein bis zum nächsten Mal ciao